Hey Youtubers
it's Charlie so everyone's going crazy about iron
fist let's break this down most of this is
going to be about the iron fist trailer what's
going on during the series but I also address
crossover with Luke Cage heroes for hire in
the classic comic book costume and the other
Netflix series like defenders and punisher
which are also dropping this year there is
a new round of the Marvel giveaway.
I'm giving away one of the Spider-Man figures.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I totally
like Clair temples introduction to that she's
kind like the explainer character Danny Randd
says I'm the iron fist and she's like what
what the hell is that supposed to mean.
So you have a lot of people that will be watching
they have no idea what's going on with iron
fist from the comics so this trailer just
spells it out a little bit more clearly.
Danny Rand comes back after plane crash when
he was a young boy he grew up in Kun-Lun sort
of interdimensional city.
I don't know how the gonna change that for
the TV show, but the way they explain his
powers in the TV show is just in the harnessing
of his Chi.
That's what you're saying when you see his
face glows so the not on fire like they are
in the comics and in the comics he got some
of those powers when he plunged his fist into
the heart of the Dragon.
So the song that they play in the trailer
is a bit of a wink at that it's a posh a I'm
a Dragon.
So this is meant to be a very real world iron
fist, it's not exactly like the comics is
always minor changes.
So for instance you have the Meachum children
in Danny Rand standing here is he's come back
to society.
Look I'm not dead.
This is partly my company I inherited my father
shares.
So now I'm co-owner with the Meachum in the
give office really sinister five that he used
to be very good friends with joy Meachum here
you see they have a special connection throughout
the trailer.
The other Meachum Ward Meachum doesn't like
and so much you got to get that five is pissed
pretty clear from the way they present in
the trailer.
The kingpin level big bad though is Harold
Meachum the any Randts father's former business
partner who is responsible for the plane crash,
he orchestrated that so that he could take
over the company.
So when Danny Rand is talking about the hand
infiltrating his company like you see Harold
Meachum looking at the imprint of the hand
here he's talking to Crane mother Rand enterprises
is very tied up with a hand there helping
import things you see the shipping containers
with Meachum on the side.
This is sort of a call back to daredevil season
two when the hand was trying to import black
sky, so that they could raise the demon that
they're worshiping.
So now that sort of an electro storyline,
but is very daredevil centric.
So now you getting some crossover with iron
fist.
So his company is sort of the infrastructure
that the hand is using to accomplish their
goals.
The other villains you see him fighting here
this is sort of like the small that is Zhou
Chang in the comics he serves as the host
for this demon is trying to get at iron fist
power the source of his power, the Dragon.
So I don't know Heather can incorporate the
actual Dragon the source of iron fist power
to this.
It seems like the tone that down a little
bit.
So maybe he just knows how to harness his
Chi the same way that iron fist does.
So Zhou Chang works with Crane mother who
is working with the hand who is using Harold
Meachum to import all of their resources,
you probably recognize Jessica Henwick as
Colleen Wing just kicking a whole lot of ass
at the end of Luke Cage Clare Temple pull
that little tab off the martial arts lessons
bulletin that's for Colleen Wing's classes
so she teaches self-defense but she's also
this ally of iron fist in the comics she doesn't
have quite the mystical origin that he does
her family descends from a line of bad asses.
So all this craziness is in her blood and
she does know how to Horner's her Chi in the
same way that iron fist does but she's not
quite as powerful.
So that's probably why you don't see her face
glowing like his, but a lot of the scenes
in the trailer here stuff that they showed
off a comic con him walking in the funny scene
of him getting carded out by the security
guard just taking them down like it's nobody's
business the iron fist version of the daredevil
hallway fight that all the Netflix series
about Luke Cage got his version of that iron
fist is going to have his then showing off
a little bit about the magnitude of his power.
You can see they toned it down a little bit.
He's crazy powerful in the comics but remember,
these are supposed to be street-level heroes
so they toned down just a little bit.
So I would say he's about as powerful maybe
a little bit more powerful than power man
when he's at full strength.
Luke Cage is the strongest the most indestructible
but iron fist, it's the hardest they could
probably go toe to toe.
But as we learn from Jessica Jones you can
actually hurt Luke Cage is just his skin.
That's unbreakable not his internal organs
so it'll be fun to see the Meetup on screen
during defenders misty night is supposed to
have a cameo, but like I said, the love interest
in this is going to be calling wing.
So in the way that the Luke Cage series changed
a little bit about that in the comics misty
night and Luke Cage were really a thing in
the comics but they change that for the TV
show there also changing iron fist.
Just a little bit, but that might change when
we get to defenders the music is going to
feel very much like Luke Cage, so maybe a
lot more Wu-Tang they called Luke Cage the
Wu-Tang of vacation of the Marvel universe.
The really big thing about iron fist.
Though is that he is the only person on the
defenders that understands the true threat
the hand poses daredevil has learned a little
bit about it from stick but iron fist to spend
way more time in Kun-Lun learning about the
mystical war between the chaste in the hand.
So he's the guy to come in and say look there
a lot of problems in Harlem all over New York
City, but there's is even bigger problem in
that secret organization in this mystical
war that we need to stop.
A lot of you are asking me if Danny Rand will
get his comic book costume in the way that
daredevil got a costume Luke Cage even wore
the yellow shirt for little while.
I think that there will definitely be a version
of the costume people avast Finn Jones he's
come out and said look Marvel will kill me
and he just kind of jumped around the little
bit.
So I think that just confirms there will be
a version of the comic book costume, but it
probably won't happen until the very end of
the series like the trailer says everything
is dropping on March 17 it's a Friday.
Of course I'll be doing episodes for leave
all your request for bonus videos in the comments
below.
This can be a bunch of iron fist Defenders
stuff because defenders is coming this summer
and then the punisher series is supposed to
drop at the end of the year.
So there will be three new Netflix series
dropping this year it's going to be hardcore
while you wait for that next video you can
click here to rewatch all the Super Bowl trailers
and you can click here to learn about the
different colors of lightning on the flash
thank you so much for watching everybody high
five I'll see the next video!